. Herzlich willkommen zu Folge 8 des Podcast-Ufos, Ihr Podcast für Fun, Fun, Fun. Heute präsentiert von Achtung, Achtung, heute mit Stefan Tietze und Tietze und mit Florian Woll. Und falls ihr denkt, dass wir wieder diese gute alte, gute, schlechte, guter Podcast, schlechter Podcast, guter Podcast Reihenfolge bringen, wie sonst immer, nein! Wir schaffen es diesmal zwei gute Podcasts in Folge zu präsentieren und dafür ist Stefan Titzel persönlich verantwortlich mit seinem guten Namen, denn... Diese Folge wird präsentiert von Volvo. Ja, ich habe nämlich, vielleicht sollten wir Werbung machen, habe ich gerade eben überlegt. Sollten wir nicht Werbung machen? Also das ist doch der Sinn von Medien, die dadurch finanziert, dass sie halt Werbung schalten. Ja, wir machen Werbung für dich durchgehend. Aber falls ihr denkt, wir haben nur dummes Rumgelaber heute zu bieten, nein, wir haben auch fantastische Themen ausgegraben, und zwar Wie kommt es auf dieser Einbahnstrasse eines Satzes wieder raus? Weil wir haben nur ein Thema. Durch Überleitungen. Aus schlechten Sätzen kommt man generell mit Überleitungen raus, man hört einfach auf zu reden und der Gesprächspartner versornte das als Aufforderung ansehen, zu sprechen. Das mache ich auch in normalen Gesprächen so. Unser Thema ist heute Sport. Sport. Aber es ist, finde ich, eine gute Art zu reden, dieses und dein Name ist? Mein Name ist Stefan und dein Name ist? Gut, vergelte, mein Name ist Florian Will. Ich habe gerade einen heissen Tweet am Laufen, ich bin gerade ein bisschen abgelenkt, weil bei mir ist es immer so, wenn ich einen Tweet raushaue, dann starre ich nur auf den Felfbalken und haurein, äh, haurein, beobachte, beobachte, haurein, die steife Briefe mir um die Ohren behen, beziehungsweise was ich eigentlich sagen wollte,, beobachte, die steufe Briefe mir um die Ohren wehen, beziehungsweise, was ich eigentlich sagen wollte, ich beobachte, welche Fails ich bekomme. Und deswegen bin ich gerade ein bisschen abgelehnt, weil ich habe gerade einen Murder-Geld. Du löscht auch Tweets, wenn sie nicht gut laufen, oder? Richtig, ich lösche auch Tweets, wenn sie nicht gut laufen, weil man ist ja teilweise, ich bin ein sehr selbstbewusster Typ, aber manchmal denkt man sich auch, ob der ist jetzt hundertprozentig wahr, dann lässt man den Plebus entscheiden, ob er ihn annehmen möchte, ja oder nein. Und das finde ich ist auch ein absolut legitimes Mittel, dessen man sich dann belohnt. Machst du irgendwann mal, veröffentlichtest du auch so ein Buch dann mit allen Tweets, die du nicht veröffentlicht hast, so das Worst of des Florentin Will? Das finde ich eine gute Idee, aber ich bin tatsächlich sehr wählerisch, was meine Tweets angeht. Also ich bin nicht so jemand, der jeden Scheiss raushaut. Merkt man gar nicht. Wir haben eine Nachricht bekommen auf Facebook, es hat tatsächlich jemand geantwortet. Wir haben in der letzten Woche gefragt, wer ihr seid, was für Menschen ihr seid. Das glaubt uns doch jetzt niemand. Niemand glaubt uns das, wenn wir denn jetzt sie vorlesen. Ich lese sie vor, sie ist von einer gewissen, sehr hochgeschätzten Pauline S. Sie schreibt, guten Morgen, um euch endlich mal den Wunsch zu erfüllen, Hörerpost zu bekommen, hier eine Beschreibung meiner Person. Ich lese es übrigens genauso vor, wie es da steht. Ich bin 20 Jahre alt und aus Tübingen, im Übrigen die schönste Stadt der Welt, aber das nur am Rande, zwei Klammern zu und studiere Gesang. Ich bin eine Person, die in eine Buchhandlung geht, genau weiss, was die will, aber sich trotzdem mich helfen lässt. Lieber suche ich eine Stunde nach dem Buch alleine und tue so, als würde ich einfach wirklich, als würde ich einfach willkürlich stöbern. Das kann ich auch gut nachvollziehen, würde ich auch. In Wirklichkeit ist das alles aber komplett gelogen. Ich habe seit drei Jahren kein Buch mehr fertig gelesen, aber es wäre so, wenn ich es tun würde, erwartungsvoll, stets, eure Pauline. Auch sehr gut, noch am Ende so ein Insider-Witz aufgegriffen.
Natürlich, aber meine Frage, man kann nicht einfach einen Text schreiben und darunter erwartungsvoll schreiben, weil Erwartungen auf was, was erwartet sie denn? Ich meine, wenn man irgendwie eine Frage stellt, auf Antwort wartend, okay, aber du kannst nicht einfach nur sagen, hey, wie geht's, erwartungsvoll, eure Pauline. Singend, mordend, eure Pauline. Ich fühle mich da direkt unter Zugzwang, irgendwas zu erfüllen, was ich nicht erfüllen kann. Wir haben auch nicht geantwortet. Pauline, du stellst so eine Anforderung. Wir haben auch nicht geantwortet. Wir haben auch nicht geantwortet. Wir werden auch nicht antworten, das ist jetzt eine Antwort. Aber vielen Dank natürlich für die Post. Uns interessiert immer, welche Leute das ... Und natürlich kannst du dir sicher sein, liebe Pauline, dass ich deinem Facebook-Profil einer berühmt-berüchtigten Florentin-Will-Stalking-Session unterzogen habe. Ich habe jedes schmutzige Geheimnis herausgefunden. Und da kommt einiges zu Tage, meine Liebe. Da würde ich mal ein bisschen aufpassen. Hast du auch ... Wir sollten mal vielleicht Marktforschung anstellen, wie unsere Hörerschaft bislang aussieht. Wir haben so ein paar Faves auf Facebook und so ein paar Freunde auf Twitter. Ich glaube, mittlerweile kann man das noch ganz gut machen. So in zwei Monaten, wenn wir 300.000 Hörer haben, wird es schwierig. Aber mittlerweile, glaube ich, kann man sagen, zwei kommen aus Süddeutschland und drei kommen aus Norddeutschland. Das kann man ganz gut machen eigentlich. Ist aber noch keine repräsentative Mehrheit. Das heißt, wir können noch nicht sagen, unsere Hörer kommen eher aus Norddeutschland als aus Süddeutschland, sind eher Raucher oder sterben an Krebs im nächsten Jahr. Das können wir noch nicht sagen, weil das ist ja noch nicht statistisch relevant. Dafür brauchen wir tausend, glaube ich. Ich finde es zwar gut, dass du Themenvorschläge bringst, dass du dich in die Planung dieser Sendung mit einbringst, jetzt möchte ich aber noch mal zu deinem Themenvorschlag Sport noch mal ein bisschen nachführen. Wie man arschlochmässig auf das nächste Thema hinaus überleitet. Florentin Will, Liste auf das Drei. Ich kenne genau deine Scheissstrategie. Du schlägst beschissene Themen vor und verlässt dich dann einfach darauf, dass unsere Zuschauer Content liefern, den du ausschlachten kannst minutenlang, damit wir nie auf das Thema kommen. Aber so nicht, mein Lieber. Ich will dir heute mal zeigen, was das für Konsequenzen hat, wenn man ein scheiß Thema an Land zieht. So, jetzt reden wir über Sport. Ja, tolles Thema Sport. Was treibst du denn für Sportarten? Das hast du nur gemacht jetzt, weil du dich nicht vorbereitet hast, weil du eben im Kino warst. Sag doch mal, wie das Kino war. Es war toll. Es war ein Tweetwert. Nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, es war ein Tweetwert und der Tweet geht gerade Trending parallel. Geht steil. Aber Tweets können nicht trenden. Nee, Wie ist es mit Sport? Ist Kino gehen für dich ein Sport? Vielleicht ist das ganze Leben ein Sport. Was definiert denn eigentlich ein Sport? Was ist der Unterschied zwischen Sport und Spiel? Sport ist eher im Sinne körperlicher Betätigung, Spiel ist im Sinne psychischer Belustigung. Wir können auch gleich wieder die klassische E-Sport-Variante Diskussioniskussion aufreißen, im Sinne von, ist E-Sport echter Sport? Ja, ja, klar, mit dieser Wii-Fitness-Matte. Wii-Fitness hat sich völlig zu Unrecht nicht durchgesetzt. Ich hätte damals gedacht, jeder hat irgendwann diese Wii-Matte. Wohl bei meinem Thema wären, übrigens nebenbei, aber gut, mach weiter. Ne, jetzt möchte ich auch hören, was du zu sagen hast. Wer mich so link unterbricht, bitte. Nein, also die Diskussion habe ich schon ewig geführt, E-Sport, echter Sport, ja, aber Schach ist auch kein echter Sport und Billard ist auch kein Sport und Dart ist auch kein Sport und hier und da ist fälliger Schwachsinn. Sport hat für mich nichts mit körperlicher Betätigung zu tun, das ist Athletik, das ist Präzision, ja, aber das ist eigentlich eine scheiß langweilige Diskussion, aber mich würde interessieren, welche Sportarten führst du denn? Bist du ein sportlicher Typ, was machst du denn so? Im Moment mache ich nicht so viel. Gebe mich ganz offen und ehrlich zu. Ich sollte mehr machen, ich sollte mehr tun. Und als Kind mal irgendwie Flöte gelernt oder sowas. Musik ist ja auch Sport im Grunde. Warum redest du so schnell? Wir werden auch trotzdem eine Stunde reden müssen, wenn du jetzt schneller redest. Ich habe eigentlich noch echt viel zu tun heute, deswegen möchte ich es schnell rumbringen.
Ich habe damals echt als Kind einigermaßen viele Sportarten ausprobiert.
Ich habe Fußball angefangen zu spielen,
habe dann auch mal zwischendurch Judo
gemacht, ausgeübt,
versucht auszuüben, dann habe ich
Tennis lange gemacht, war auch
mal im Fitnessstudio eine Zeit lang, also ich habe
sehr viel kreuz und quer
mal ausprobiert, rumprobiert. Ich habe tatsächlich
auch einiges gemacht, dafür, dass ich jetzt komplett unsportlich
und unfähig bin, überhaupt zu bewegen. Wann ist das eigentlich
Vielen Dank. auch mal im Fitnessstudio eine Zeit lang. Also ich habe sehr viel kreuz und quer mal ausprobiert, rumprobiert. Ich habe tatsächlich auch einiges gemacht, dafür, dass ich jetzt komplett unsportlich und unfähig bin. Wann ist das eigentlich zu Bruch gegangen? Wann hast du mit deinem Leben eigentlich abgeschlossen? Das kann ich jetzt nicht genau sagen, aber ich möchte es chronologisch angehen. Und zwar war ich früher in Karate tatsächlich, habe ich gemacht mit einem Freund von mir und später noch alleine. Und ich kann mich da noch an eine Geschichte erinnern, und zwar hatte ich gerade meinen Nintendo DS bekommen, was wirklich das krasseste war, dass es jemals gab. Mit Tekken und dann wolltest du unbedingt Karate spielen. Ne, ne, ne, da war ich schon im Karateverein und mit Super Mario und krassen Spielen. Und dann dachte ich mir, mein Vater hat mich immer zum Karate-Training gefahren, und dann dachte ich mir, hm, vielleicht heute, statt tatsächlich in die Halle zu gehen und Karate zu praktizieren, um zu lernen, wie man vor Leuten wegläuft, die einem angreifen wollen, nehme ich meinen DS mit, schmuggel den mit und verkrieche mich dann einfach irgendwo ausserhalb der Halle, sodass auch niemand merkt, dass ich überhaupt da war, und spiele einfach DS. Das kann ich mir genau vorstellen, wie so ein kleiner Junge, so verloren, draußen irgendwo sitzt, in seinem Turnbeutel, der ihm gepackt wurde, weil seine Eltern ihn zum Sport gezwungen haben. Haben deine Eltern nicht gezwungen oder wolltest du von dir aus fahren? Nee, nee, ich wollte schon selbstständig. Aber es war so, beim Karate hat man immer so diesen weissen Anzug an, obwohl ich eigentlich keinen Karateanzug hatte, sondern einen Judoanzug. und die unterscheiden sich darin, dass die Judoanzüge so einen ganz dicken Kragen haben,
weil man beim Judo ja immer so den Gegner packen muss und beim Karate eigentlich nicht.
Deswegen hatte ich eigentlich den von meinem Bruder, der Judo betrieben hat,
erstmal schon mal den komplett falschen, der immer zu heiß war, weil er viel zu dick war.
Aber es war gerade Winter und deswegen dachte ich mir, wenn ich jetzt die ganze Zeit draußen rumsitze,
wird mir bestimmt wahnsinnig kalt, deswegen war ich ganz clever und habe zu Hause, bevor ich da hingefahren bin, unter meinem Karate-Anzug normale Kleidung angezogen, also eine Trainingshose und T-Shirt und Pullover und darüber alles. Das heißt, mein Vater und ich haben gedacht, okay, gut, mein Sohn hat über Nacht zehn Kilo zugenommen, gut, dass wir ihn ins Karate schicken. Jetzt läuft es aber folgendermassen raus. Ich stehe dann da, spielte es irgendwie, es ging gerade los, ich sofort wollte Super Mario spielen und dann kam irgendwann so ein anderer Vater, weil mein Vater hat mich immer nur vor der Schule abgesetzt und andere Eltern sind mit ihren Kindern direkt in die Halle gegangen. Weil du ihm peinlich warst. Genau, weil ich plötzlich über Nacht zehn Kilo zugenommen hatte und die Blödsinn wollte es ihm meinen Vater nicht geben. Was machen die mit ihrem Sohn? Auf jeden Fall war es dann so, dass die Karatestunde ausgefallen ist tatsächlich, dass aber niemand wissen konnte, sondern dass das nur durch einen Anschlag an der Halle tatsächlich kommuniziert wurde. Das heißt, ein anderer Vater, der mit seinem Sohn da gerade hingegangen ist, hat das gesehen und die Karte ist schon sich ausgefallen, sie war nur in einer anderen Halle. Und dann hat dieser Vater sich so umgesehen, ob da noch andere Kinder waren, die verloren waren, hat mich gesehen, hat gesagt, ja, hast du gesehen, die Karte-Training ist in einer anderen Halle, sollen wir dich mitnehmen, wir sind mit dem Auto da. Ja, gut, blöde Frage. Wenn es sein jetzt die pädophilen Karte so, ich darf nicht so fremden, erwachsenes Auto, aber er hatte offensichtlich ein Kind dabei, das auch einen Karateanzug dabei hat. Na ja, gut, vielleicht war es einfach ein sehr sorgfältiger Pädophiler, der einfach ... Ja, sehr guter Plan, ja, der schon einen Sklaven hat. Ja, genau. Auf jeden Fall, anders geht es ja eigentlich nicht, weil ich sage, ja, okay, ja, ich komme mit, bin da hingefahren in die andere Halle und konnte dann auch nicht fliehen auf dem Weg dahin und auch in das Training nicht. Das heißt, ich bin dann mit dem Vater und mit dem anderen Kind ins Training gegangen, in die Halle gegangen, da haben mich alle gesehen und ich habe dann ein eineinhalb stündiges Karate-Training komplett durchgezogen mit normaler Kleidung unter meinem Karateanzug. Ich habe geschwitzt wie ein Schwein. Ich war völlig fertig, war völlig am Boden. Niemand konnte auch nur ansatzweise verstehen, weil ich habe die Kleidung sehr gut versteckt und habe die dann so überall so reingestopft. Das heißt, sie war teilweise wirklich relativ dick. Und das erinnere ich mich noch, dass das eine Katharsis war, die ich erlebt habe und mir da gesagt habe, nie wieder Sport, nie wieder, war ich nie wieder. Hattest du andere Gürtel auch oder hattest du immer diesen weissen Gürtel behalten, den man am Anfang hat? Aber da hast du wirklich ein bisschen aufgeschieden. Ich habe es kurz vor den grünen Gürteln geschafft. Also ich hatte weiss, gelb, orange und dann kurz vor der Prüfung zum grünen habe ich dann letztendlich aufgesprochen. Ich habe kurz vor der ersten Prüfung, wo man dann diesen weissgelben Gürtel bekommt, habe ich auch gehört. Genau, der weissgelbe, da war ich ja nie ein Fan davon, den hatte ich ja auch nie. Nee, weiss-gelb hat mir farblich nicht gefallen und dann wollte ich auch die Prüfung nicht absolvieren und dann bin ich einfach davor, dem Verein habe ich mich entsagt, dem Verein. Ich habe den vierten Platz bei dem Karate-Turnier gewonnen, also so ist es nicht, ich kann schon was. Wow, ey, das heißt, du kannst schon Menschen umbringen, alleine mit deinen bösen Händen.
Ja, ja, aber da gab es echt so fiese Tricks,
also wir waren alle Kinder und klein und so,
aber es war echt ein bisschen wie so ein Sportfilm, weil es war kein wirkliches Turnier, wo man generell kämpft,
sondern man hat so eigengestudierte Choreografien
und die macht man dann mit einem Gegner
sozusagen, aber halt so in Körperkontakt
war alles einstudiert. Und wer gewinnt dann am Ende?
Keiner. Ja, und dann bewertet eine Jury,
wer eben die Schläge besser ausgeführt hat
und wessen Körperhaltung, bla, blub.
Aber mein Trainer hat mir kurz davor gesagt, so hier, Flo und
Vielen Dank. Hä? Und wer gewinnt denn am Ende? Keiner. Ja, und dann bewertet eine Jury, wer eben die Schläge besser ausgeführt hat und wessen Körperhaltung, bla bla bla. Aber mein Trainer hat mir kurz davor gesagt, so hier, Florian Team, pass mal auf. Hier, wenn du dann in dem und dem Moment irgendwie deinen Arm hier so gegen seine Schulter drückst, dann bringst du ihn aus dem Gleichgewicht und so. Dann bringst du ihn um. Genau, da ist er tot, ritzte seine Kehle auf. Und weil du sowieso deine Faust an seiner Schulter hast, merkt es niemand. Das habe ich gemacht und es hat tatsächlich funktioniert. Und ich habe mich so schlecht gefühlt und ich habe immer noch diese Medaille des vierten Platzes, aber ich fühle mich so schlecht, weil ich sie eigentlich nicht wirklich verdient habe. Aber es gehört auch dazu. Deswegen liegt die irgendwo bei dir versteckt. Ist es nicht so, also ich habe Karate immer so wahrgenommen, ich habe ja damals Judo gemacht, wie gesagt, bis zum ersten Gürtel und ich habe das irgendwie so wahrgenommengenommen, als wäre Judo immer der kleine Bruder von Karate.
Bei Karate wird es dann richtig schmerzhaft.
Und da kommen dann die blauen Flecken,
und da kommt dann der Anzug, wo es auch wehtut. Aber ich glaube, es ist eigentlich genau anders.
Beim Judo wird man ja eher durch die Gegend geworfen.
Genau.
Wo man beim Karate, beim normalen Training,
eigentlich keinen Körperkontakt hat,
weil du kannst ja nie einfach jemandem in die Fresse hauen.
Beim Judo gefühlt ja.
Beim Judo habe ich das auch bei einem Training schon, als es total unangenehm war. Erst mal kommst du da in die Halle und dann muss man ja diese japanischen Grüße machen, von denen man nicht genau weiß, was man da sagt und alle wiederholen da irgendwelche Dinge und man weiß nicht genau, was man da sagt und das wurde auch nie irgendwie erklärt. Das war mir schon ein bisschen suspekt, wo dann so ein Führer vorne steht, wir stehen in so Reihen angeordnet und knien uns auf Kommando hin und beten da irgendwie so einen Drachen an der Wand an oder was. Was ist das denn? Und dann hat mir noch nie jemand erklärt, was man da sagt und vielleicht habe ich da irgendwie gesagt, ich bringe alle weissen Menschen auf der Welt um oder keine Ahnung was. Ich bin jetzt im Dienst, vielleicht habe ich auch irgendeinem Ding Eid geschworen, irgendeinem japanischen Gott oder so. Wahrscheinlich kommt die Yakuza irgendwann in fünf Jahren bei dir vorbei und sagt, du hast damals auf dein Leben geschworen, dass du uns hilfst, ab im Bus. Ja, genau, davor habe ich nämlich Angst. Glaubst du, die wollen dich heute noch? Nein, das glaube ich nicht. Ich glaube, die sind nicht schnell. Ich war tatsächlich damals recht interessiert in diese ganze asiatische Geschichte und Kultur und wie das alles läuft und so und habe immer Fragen gestellt. Hattest du eine Asienphase? Ja, also jetzt nicht so, also heute würde man die Asienphase wahrscheinlich anders deuten, so mit Anime und Manga und quietsch quietsch, aber damals war es noch so Karate Kid Ninja Turtles Asierphase, das war doch richtig cool. Cool, das war gut. Und da war es dann so, also in dem Dojo, also man sagt ja nicht Trainingshalle, sondern Dojo, obwohl nebenbei auch die Ü50-Dame mit ihren Sportgymnastik-Mannsieren. Schwange, es ist trotzdem ein Dojo. Und zwar ist es so, dass sich die ganzen Schüler und Lehrer am Anfang, wie du schon gesagt hast, in einer Reihe hinknien, und zwar nach den Gürtelfarben geordnet. Da habe ich mal gefragt, und zwar beginnt es mit dem niedrigsten Gürtel, wenn man ins Dojo reinkommt, bis zu dem höchsten Gürtel auf der anderen Seite. Also wenn man zur Tür reingeht, dann folgt man der Gürtelfarbe Aufsteigen. Da habe ich gefragt, warum das so ist und warum die nicht andersrum sitzen. Und dann hat mein Trainer mir die Antwort gegeben, ja, ja, das kommt daher, weil früher wurde auch das Militär oder so in irgendeiner Situation oder halt generell Ninjas oder so, als es noch fucking serious business war, wurden die auch so gekämpft. Und dann war die Idee, dass wenn Feinde das Dojo angreifen und durch die Tür kommen, sie sich erst mal an den ganzen schlechten Kämpfern abarbeiten und die alle umbringen und wegmetzeln.
Wisst ihr?
Und wenn sie zu den Guten kommen, sind sie ganz müde und dann können die guten Kämpfer sie einfach besiegen.
Und bis heute erschliesst sich mir diese Logik nicht wirklich.
Weil wenn ich das machen würde, ich würde es genau andersrum machen. Ich würde dafür sorgen, dass die guten Kämpfer die schlechten beschützen und nicht auf den Ermattungsrefekt des Abschlachtens von jungen Schülern auf. Wenn du in einer Asienphase besser aufgepasst hättest, dann hättest du wahrscheinlich gemerkt, dass die Asiaten halt die schlechten, glaube ich, loswerden wollen. Die haben gar keinen Wert in der Gesellschaft. Und wir beide wären dann zum Beispiel die ersten gewesen, die dann gestorben wären. Und das wäre auch irgendwie wahrscheinlich auch gut gewesen. Also es hätten die anderen gut gefunden, dass da jetzt zwei Schwächlinge nicht mehr in den Reihen sind. Man ist immer nur so stark wie ein schwächtes Glied. Aber wie ist es dann für die Feinde? Weil die Feinde wollen ja dann möglichst die Schwachen der Gegner am Leben lassen. Die wollen ja möglichst nur die Starken der Gegner töten und die Schwachen nicht. Ja, genau. Weil wenn es ein Vorteil ist, die Schwachen loszuwerden, gibt es ja keinen Sinn, die Schwachen zu töten des Gegners. Also du meinst, dass jetzt die Idee ist, dass sie die Schwachen gar nicht angreifen können, weil sie nicht töten wollen. Ich habe nicht gesagt, dass das ein durchdachtes System war. Ich habe nicht gedacht, dass es durchdacht ist. Ich habe nur gesagt, so will es gehen. Du bist überhaupt nicht durchdacht. Nee. Das ist ein Nulldurchdacht. Wahnsinnig dämlich. Ich war mal ein Fan von den Ägyptern damals. Also wahrscheinlich in der Phase, in der du die Asiaten bewundert hast, habe ich die Ägypten bewundert. Du hast ja schon mal erzählt, dass du immer so phasenweise für gewisse Themen interessierst. Klar, immer so Sitcom, Peter Griffin-mäßig. Und das war aber wirklich damals so, dass viele Bücher eigentlich relativ verherrlichen diese ganzen Ägypter-Sachen und dargestellt haben. Und im Endeffekt haben die ja ganz schön viele Milliarden, Trilliarden Menschen umgebracht als Sklaven für die Pyramiden zum Beispiel. Ja, absolut. Das waren absolute Arschlöcher eigentlich. Da war die Idee, die Schwachen müssen weg. Und wie machen wir das am besten? Wir bauen irgendwie einen riesigen Quader in die Welt. Wir setzen sie in einen Raum und sie sollen einen Podcast machen. Ja, mittlerweile interessierst du dich nur noch für Podcasts, oder? Ja, das ist meine Phase im Moment. Wobei, ich habe heute zum Beispiel meine Phase, habe ich jetzt eine Photoshop-Phase. Ich wollte nämlich heute ein Logo für uns machen, ein besseres. Ja, ich fand die eigentlich so gut. Unser altes Logo ist scheiße. Also ich muss sagen, ich finde es ja, der Unterschied zwischen unserem alten Logo und dem neuen Logo ist, dass auf unserem neuen Logo gross draufsteht, mit Stefan Titze und Florentin Will.
Ich kann ja verstehen, dass du deinen Namen... Ich wollte eigentlich nur meinen Namen draufschreiben. Ja, ich kann ja verstehen, dass du deinen Namen gerne öffentlich präsentieren möchtest, aber diese Logos sind extrem klein. Auch in iTunes sind die wirklich klein. Du hast so kleine Striche, sieht man da nur. Das sieht aus wie so ein Fleck auf dem Bildschirm und dann kratzen die Leute wieder mit dem Bildschirm rum und streicheln dem Logo über die Wange und es sieht einfach nicht gut aus, es funktioniert nicht. Ich dachte, der Gedanke war, dass dein Name, du wurdest karikiert, ich kann es nicht auf genug sagen, du wurdest karikiert, das heißt für mich, du hast eine neue Stufe der Prominenz erreicht und deswegen sollten wir mit deinem Namen hausieren gehen. Und ich glaube, das würden die Leute anziehen. Das ist ja auch ein guter Name, wenn man Florentin will. Heißt, würde ich mir das auch anhören. Ich habe auch noch Handball gespielt früher. Ich weiß nicht, ob mein Trainer das einfach nur erfunden hat, um mich zu demütigen. Aber im Handball ist es ja so, dass es einen relativ protokollierten Ablauf eines Spielzuges gibt. Da stehen ja alle Spieler dann in so einem Halbkreis ums Tor rum und versuchen zu verteidigen, und die andere Mannschaft steht in einem etwas grösseren Halbkreis umrum und dann passen ja alle hin und her. Und ich hatte aber die Rolle des Kaschball. Und der Kaschball war der einzige, der diese Struktur verlassen durfte und dem angreifenden Gegner entgegenrennen durfte und da schon versucht hat, den Aufbau zu stören und den Ball abzufangen und die Spieler zu behindern. Und alle anderen standen in der Formation und ich bin da voll rumgesprungen wie so ein Kaschball und durfte das machen. Ich weiß nicht, ob es in der Handball-Liebesposition möglich gibt oder ob es einfach nur ein Begriff war für, du bist einfach völlig nutzlos. Ja, das kann sein.
Bitte verlass die Struktur. Also allein der Name, beim Namen wäre ich schon misstrauisch geworden. Ja, genau, wenn irgendwie Libero oder so, okay gut, das klingt Kasperl. Und dann war es wirklich so, wir waren alle gleich alt, die ganze Mannschaft, meine ganzen Freunde waren in der Mannschaft und wir waren die Minis, weil wir in noch keiner Jugend waren. Und dann kamen alle in die E-Jugend, nur ich nicht. Obwohl ich sagte, ja, aber der zum Beispiel, der ist ein paar Monate jünger als ich, warum kommt denn der in die E-Jugend? Und dann das Argument meines Trainers, ja, du bleibst bei den Minis, weil auch die Minis brauchen einen Guten, zu dem sie aufschauen können. Und ich dachte, hast du eigentlich einen Schaden? Nein, du hast doch geglaubt, du hast doch geglaubt. Und Florentin, jetzt machen wir ein Spiel zurück, wo du dich auf die Bank setzen musst. Mach das mal, mach das mal. Okay, ja, I win. Genau, du spielst den Banker, du stehst hinter dem gegnerischen Tor und fängst den Ball, wenn er nicht trifft. Mama, heute war ich Banker, wow, wir sind stolz auf dich. Nee, aber ich habe wirklich mit der Minute auch sofort aufgehört, Handball zu spielen, weil ich mit meinen Freunden spielen wollte. Aber ich meine, was ist das für eine Scheiss-Argumentation? Irgendwie, du kriegst kein Abi, weil die Zwölfklässler wollen auch jemanden haben, der älter ist als sie, zu dem sie aufschauen können. Nein, sie schauen dann eben gerade nicht zu dir auf, weil er älter ist als man selbst und er spielt auf der gleichen Position wie man selbst. Genau zu der Person schaut man eben nicht auf. Man denkt sich, was bist du für ein Depp, dass du immer noch mit uns spielst.
Ich habe dann, ich habe relativ früh mit
Fussball angefangen, weil auch meine ganzen Freunde angefangen haben,
Fussball zu spielen und wir hatten Vereine relativ
in der Nähe und ich war
nie wirklich, ich war nie wirklich
gut. Also ich war immer sehr, sehr schlecht
und wurde dann in die Abwehr gestellt.
Das zielt sich so ein bisschen wie ein roter Faden
durch dein Leben. Ich war nie gut in dem, was ich gerade mache,
genau. Ja. Und dann wurde ich in dem, was ich gerade mache, genau.
Und dann wurde ich in die Abwehr gestellt und ich kann mich noch erinnern, im ersten Spiel war es dann so, es war keiner talentiert wirklich in dem ganzen Team, auch der Torwart nicht. Deswegen hat man von dem Team vielleicht auch noch nichts gehört, könnte sein, dass es ein Grund ist. Und dann, da gehe ich jetzt wieder nicht drauf ein, und dann stand ich in der Abwehr und unser Torwart, der auch nicht so gut war, hat dann den Ball abgeschlagen, aber leider so, dass er genau mich getroffen hat, mich, der gerade irgendwie fünf Meter vorm Torwart steht, richtig draufgebollert. Und dann lag ich wirklich so zehn Sekunden bewusstlos am Boden. Das war mein erstes Spiel, Fussball. Und wir haben 20 zu 1 verloren, glaube ich. Also es war wirklich, es war ein Fussballergebnis, was man so noch nicht gesehen hatte, glaube ich. Und alle Eltern waren so ganz stolz. Erstmal ein neuer Verein wurde gegründet, die standen alle am Rand. Man hat so gemerkt, während des Spiels haben sie sich so langsam von uns abgewendet, weil es auch wirklich sichtbar peinlich war. Aber immerhin zu 1, das geht ja noch. Es war ein Erfolg, es war schon ein Erfolg, ein Tor zu schaffen, das hatte der Trainer nicht erwartet, glaube ich. Und dann habe ich relativ zeitig mich entschieden, dann den Sport zu wechseln, weil ich glaube, ich habe das eben aufs Team geschoben, meine Unfähigkeit. Und dann habe ich angefangen, Tennis zu spielen. Oh, Tennis ist auch nicht schlecht. Und das auch teilweise auch relativ lange, jetzt bis vor einem Jahr, bis ich umgezogen bin und dann eigentlich auch, ja, annähernd erfolgreich. Also ganz gut sogar. Cool. Das war ganz nett. Ich habe mir dann eine spezielle Aufschlagtechnik zugelegt. Wo ich mir dachte... Von der Bank aus. Genau. Nee, weil ich dachte, das ist ja der erste Schlag, immer, ne, ein Aufschlag, eröffnet ja jedes Spiel, wenn man den Aufschlag grandios gut drüberbringt. Dann kann man schnell wieder nach Hause. Dann kann man schnell wieder nach Hause und hat auch Chancen, auch wenn man spielerisch nicht überzeugt und konditionell schon mal gar nicht überzeugen kann, dass man dann vielleicht eine Chance hat, zu gewinnen. Was ist eigentlich der beste Sport der Welt, deiner Meinung nach? Der beste Sport der Welt. Was guckst du überhaupt von Sport? Guckst du Fußballussball zum Beispiel? Ist er jetzt? Ja, Fussball halt nur bei WM und E-M, aber ansonsten interessiert es mich überhaupt nicht. Was ich ganz, ganz gerne mag, ist Dart. Dart? Gucken auch viele von uns an. Nee, aber also früher, als ich noch einen Fernseher hatte und wahnsinnig viel gefahrensäht habe und viel gesappt habe, da habe ich dann nicht immer bei Eurosport hängen geblieben, war ich den ganzen Tag nur Snooker, Zerring oder Dartler. Supergeil, ich habe es nie verstanden, aber ich fand es immer geil, die Kugeln sahen immer so schön bunt aus und alle waren gut, alle, die es gespielt haben. Es wirkt irgendwie auch so ein bisschen, naja, es führt zu nichts, der schiesst die rote Kugel rein und dann legt er die wieder auf den Tisch und du denkst, ja Kinder, wie lange soll ich die mit zum Zuschauen? Genau, immer an der Programmzeit, die haben geguckt, wie soll das denn gehen? Hat der Typ den Regeln nicht verstanden oder wo soll das denn hinführen? Und auf einmal war es vorbei, obwohl noch Kugeln auf dem Feld waren und dann hat einer plötzlich gewonnen, da stand irgendwie 2 zu 1 ziemlich. Und irgendwie war immer der gleiche dran, es war immer ein Mr. Mac Smith oder so und ein anderer. Es waren eigentlich immer die gleichen Spieler, die man dann irgendwann schon kannte, weil man das immer geguckt hat. Ja, Curling finde ich auch so faszinierend. Ich stelle mir immer so einen Curling-Headhunter, so einen Talentscout vor, wie er so durch die Strassen geht und irgendwie so eine junge, talentierte Frau fegt gerade so den Vorhof, fegt gerade rum, dann kommt sie hin, sie fegen verdammt gut. Haben Sie schon mal was von Curling gehört? Und dann wird die direkt auf die Curlingbahn verfrachtet und fegt den Rest ihres Lebens. Curling ist aber auch eher so eine Sportart, wo man bei den Olympischen Spielen gemobbt wird, wenn man das macht. Wo man so intern dann abends bei den Feiern der Länder dann auch gemobbt wird. Also ich würde die Curling von den Bobfahrern. Ich glaube, die sind auch nicht so weit da oben. Ich glaube, die Skifahrer sind sehr weit. Ich habe gestern mir mal Slalom angeschaut im Fernsehen. Sehr interessant. Sieht sehr schnell aus alles. Und man versteht es eher als Snooker. Weil man einfach nur durch irgendwelche Tore fahren muss. Und Snooker ist, glaube ich, willkürlich. Was muss man denn am Ende ... Am Ende muss die Schwarzkugel auch rein. War das so? Keine Ahnung, du kriegst irgendwie so Punkte, aber das ist auch komisches System und dann kriegst du dann einen Multiplikator und wenn du es irgendwie schaffst, wenn die Kugel sich dreht oder wenn man es irgendwie schafft, für vier Mal um den Tisch zu laufen, während der Typ die Kugel noch nicht aus dem Loch wieder geholt hat, kriegt man irgendwie doppelte Punkte, irgendwie sowas, ich weiß es nicht. Ich bin ja ein sehr kreativer Mensch und ich habe tatsächlich mal selber Sportarten erfunden.
Ja.
Ich habe Sportarten erfunden.
Ich habe Sportarten erfunden, und zwar habe ich zwei Sportarten erfunden. Die erste Sportart ist Leiseball. Lass mich raten, die sind bestimmt sehr interessant, aber man muss sich nicht sehr viel bewegen. Kann das sein? Ich lasse dich selbst entscheiden, ich erkläre dir einfach mal, wie Leiseball funktioniert. Der leise Ballspieler liegt auf dem Rücken auf dem Boden und wirft den Ball in die Luft, also so über sich, und fängt ihn dann wieder auf. Und er muss diesen Ball über eine gewisse Höhe werfen, da gibt es dann so eine Markierung an der Wand, wo dann der Spieler daneben liegt, und er muss über diese Markierung werfen und dann geht es darum, den Ball möglichst leise zu fangen.
Und da ist dann so ein Mikrofon, so ein hochsensitives Mikrofon daneben und da muss man den Ball ganz leise fangen. Das ist gar nicht so leicht, probiert das mal aus. Probiert das wirklich mal aus, legt euch jetzt mal auf den Boden. Ich finde es auch nicht so einfach, den Ball schon ganz gerade, also wenn man auf dem Rücken liegt, den Ball ganz gerade nach oben zu werfen, das finde ich dann schon nicht so einfach. Das gehört natürlich dazu. Die Frage ist, dreht man den Ball an, dann hat er ja potenziell mehr Energie bekommen, als wenn er sich nicht dreht. Das heißt, man muss ihn erst ganz statisch werfen, dass er sich auf gar keinen Fall dreht, und dann eben muss man versuchen, den Auffangprozess über einen möglichst langen Zeitraum zu verteilen, damit es eher ein langes, leises Geräusch ist, statt einem lauten, kurzen Ist natürlich ein bisschen problematisch, weil ich stelle mir dann vor, bei den Olympischen Spielen irgendein Depp im Publikum brüllt rum und er pfeift und pfeift und Entschuldigung, siehe auf Platz 824, können Sie bitte leise sein, Sie verfälschen das Ergebnis und dann kappt es wieder nicht und dann hustet die. Noch geiler wäre, wenn das Publikum mit Applaus entscheiden darf, dann wer, welcher am schönsten geworfen hat, wer am leisesten war. Das Publikum darf mit einem Applaus entschieden, wer am leidesten war.
Ich finde, wenn es eine WM gäbe, bei einem Spiel, bei einer Sportart, wo das Publikum mit Applaus entscheiden kann und es dann ein amtliches Ergebnis wäre, wo es wirklich auch um viel Geld geht, das finde ich geil.
Das offizielle Applausometer. Das Applausometer, wenn das Publikum nach Applaus entscheiden kann. Das fände ich immer gut. Ja, finde ich gut. Aber was ist die Sportart? Den Ball möglichst schön hochwerfen, während man auf dem Bauch liegt. Okay, verstehe. Auf dem Bauch liegt, finde ich auch nicht schlecht. Aber natürlich darfst dein Körper natürlich auch möglichst wenig Geräusche machen. Das heißt, du bist bestenfalls komplett nackt und komplett eingeölt, damit du ja keine zusätzlichen Geräusche mit deinem Körper machst. Das heißt, im Endeffekt sieht dir das Turnier aus, dass sieben fette, eingeölte Typen nackt auf dem Rücken fliegen und versuchen, ganz leise den Ball zu fangen. Keine Zuschauer, weil alle wegen Lautstärke und Verfälschung verwiesen wurden. Genau. Ja genau, wahrscheinlich. Genau, ganz sensible Mikrofon. Und alle haben so eine halbe Stunde an so einer Sauerstoffflasche gehangen, damit sie dann die Luft anhalten können während des ganzen Wettbewerbs, weil das würde ja auch Atemgeräusche machen. Das ist ja natürlich professionell. Das sind die Profis dann, ja, auf jeden Fall. Das sind die absoluten Profis. Also ich würde nochmal darauf die Frage zurückkommen. Ich glaube, das ist keine allein subjektive Frage, was ist denn die beste
Sportart der Welt? Weil
in den USA kann man ja sagen, ist
Football die populärste Sportart
überhaupt. Ja, beliebteste Sportart.
Die populärste.
Die beste. Und in
Deutschland ist es Fussball, definitiv.
Und in anderen Ländern ist es, war ich
jetzt noch mehr, aber da habe ich mich jetzt nicht
vorbereitet und ich kenne mich da nicht aus, aber wenn man jetzt die optimalste, wenn irgendwann mal Aliens kommen und fragen Welt, was ist denn die beste Sportart, die ihr habt, dann wäre natürlich eine Antwort zu finden. Ja, ich gucke hier gerade, aber ich finde hier nur, bester Sport um abzunehmen, bester Sport um Kalorien zu verbrennen etc., aber nicht bester Sport an sich. Schwierierige Frage. Ich glaube, der Kampf Mann gegen Mann ist der beste Sport. Einfach straight forward, keine Regeln, Gladiatorenkampf, man darf sich Waffen aussuchen, dann einfach Kampf bis auf den Tod. Ich glaube, das hat sich durchgesetzt, das hat in der längsten Zeit der Menschheitsgeschichte gut gedient als Unterhaltung. Und das ist auch ein anspruchsvoller Sport, weil man muss viele Sachen machen, man muss kräftig sein, man muss aber auch schnell sein, man muss klug sein, man muss Töten können, man muss skrupellos sein. Ich finde, wo wir gerade bei dem Thema sind, Eishockey gucke ich noch gerne, also könne ich nicht, ich habe es einmal gemacht, damals für die Zeitung mussten wir das testen irgendwie, das habe ich sehr schlecht in Erinnerung, das war furchtbar, das war furchtbar.
Ich musste das testen, ich musste das testen und ich bin mit, das war eine sehr kreative Redaktion und wir sind damals mit Deutschen, das war ein Verein, wo auch deutsche Nationalspielerinnen mitgefahren sind und mitgespielt haben. Und wir durften da damals Probetraining mitmachen. Ihr habt sie sofort besiegt. Wir haben sie granadenlos fertig gemacht. Frauen sind schwach. Frauen sind schwach. Jeder, lasst das halt. Genau. Die haben uns total fertig gemacht. Unglaublich anstrengender Sport auch. Aber da ist es ja auch so ein bisschen übergeblieben, so Gladiatoren-mäßig, weil da wird sich zwischendurch einfach geprügelt. Absolut, ja. Sporttest, Fun, drei von vier Sternen, Grafik fünf von fünf. Es war genau so, Grafik scheiße, man hat einen Helm auf und sieht nicht ganz so viel dadurch. Tja. Ja, gutes Thema, Sport, kann man richtig viel und lange drüber reden, richtig gute Anekdoten auspacken. Ist ein bisschen wie Möbel. Blöd, dass wir kein zweites Thema haben, über das wir noch reden können. Blöd. Schade. Deswegen kommt jetzt hier erstmal von Mareike Amado, Can't Live Without You. Viel Spaß. So, da sind wir wieder da. Das war für euch ein toller Song. So, wir machen ein bisschen Werbung, wir sehen uns gleich wieder. Bis dann, macht's gut, ciao. Volvo. Genau. Ja, wir kommen jetzt zu unserer Service-Rubrik, und zwar Sportarten für die kalte Jahreszeit. Welche Sportarten kann man auch im Winter besonders gut machen? Es kommen ja bald, die die ersten Schnierflocken fangen anzufallen. Entschuldigung, kleiner Versprecher. Und deswegen haben wir uns heute mal Stefan Titzer eingeladen. Was sagst du, welche Sportarten kann man im Winter auch noch gut machen? Im Winter kann man besonders gut Eislaufen, ist auch mal abends ganz gut, wenn man mal nichts vorhat, mit Freunden Eislaufen gehen. Und Eis essen. Eis essen. Sehr guter Vorschlag hier von meinem Co-Moderator Florentin Wild. Übrigens, die fünf besten Stileistipps bringen wir morgen in der Service-Rubrik 18.30 Uhr. Bleibt dran. 18.30 Uhr ist glaube ich keine gute Zeit für eine Service-Rubrik. Da ist man, da ist es gerade so eine Eszeit. Man kann sehr gut Skifahren im Winter, sehr gut, ob zu Hause, in der Wohnung oder aber auch durch die Fussgängerzone fahrend, geht im Winter außerordentlich gut. Eigentlich alle Eissportarten. Skifahren habe ich auch lange gemacht, hatte ich jetzt gar nicht als Sport einkategorisiert, sondern eher so als Freizeitaktivität. Aber tatsächlich auch, ich habe alles gemacht, ich habe Snowboard gefahren, Ski und Snowblades. Was sind Snowblades? Snowblades sind einfach nur kurze Ski. Sind einfach nur 99 cm lange Ski, die aber so ein bisschen diesen Carving-Effekt haben. Also so ein bisschen vorne und hinten dicker als in der Mitte, damit man gut um die Kurve kommt. Und ich habe das gefahren eine lange Zeit. Hat man dabei so einen Propellerhelm auf? So stecken mir Leute vor, die das fahren. So ein Solarpanel auf dem Rücken. Ja, so Leute, die haben so ein Jetpack am Rücken und haben so einen Propeller auf der Nase oder auf dem Kopf. So stecken mir Leute vor, die das fahren. Genau, und du hast ja nicht wie beim Skifahren Stöcke in der Hand, sondern gar nichts einfach.
Und ich dachte immer, ich wäre der total coole Typ, weil es ist sehr einfach zu fahren, man kann springen, man kann irgendwie coole Tricks machen, man kommt sehr gut voran. Aber dann bin ich mal mit dem Lift gefahren und so über die Piste gefahren, ein paar Meter in der Höhe und habe mal einen anderen Snowblader gesehen und habe gemerkt, das sieht ja total scheiße aus. Das sieht einfach nur so aus, als würdest du einfach kerzengerade stehen und gegen deinen Willen runterfahren. Wird im Gegensatz zu Ski oder Snowboard nicht so eine coole dynamische Position links rein. Du stehst einfach nur da und fährst runter. Sieht extrem langweilig aus, weil du mit deinen Armen einfach nichts machst. Und dann unten geht dann so ein Fallschirm auf, plötzlich, damit du schnell bremst, geht dann so ein Fallschirm, löst sich und dann gleitest du aus. Ist es das?
Nein, ich glaube, das verwechselst du massiv. Aber ich glaube, da hatte ich dann immer ein bisschen Selbstbewusstsein das Problem, weil ich immer so pseudomässig mit meinen Armen in der Gegend rumgefuchtelte, um zu tun, als wäre es irgendwas Dynamisches. Ist es aber nicht. Es ist einfach nur, als würde man so eine Actionfigur, die einfach kerzengerade steht, irgendwie auf dem Stieleisstiel die Pisse runterfahren lassen. Ja. Aber Wintersport bei dir gar nicht, ne? Ich komme ja aus Bayern, da gehört das ja zum guten Ton bei dir überhaupt nicht. Doch, bei uns ist ja ein Liedersauerland, da kann man ganz gut Skifahren, war ich aber noch nicht so oft. Wir waren ja auch tatsächlich im Skilager, von der Schule aus. Ja, wir auch, Skifreizeit haben wir gemacht. Skifreizeit ist für uns. Ja, genau. Und bei uns war es dann so, also ich war davor schon lange Ski gefahren und manche halt überhaupt nicht. Und wir wurden dann immer so zu einer Art Casting eingeladen, also die ganze Gruppe halt einfach, und mussten so einen Hügel runterfahren und dann haben die Skilehrer eben bewertet, wie gut wir sind. Ja, und in welcher Gruppe man da, in welcher Anfängergruppe oder nicht vorgestellten Gruppe. Genau, es gab eins bis fünf, einzig und deppen fünf die absoluten Hardcore-Freaks und ich halt irgendwie schon jahrelange Erfahrung irgendwie Shaker so miteinander, haha, ja, fünf oder vier, mal gucken, wer es schafft von uns. Fahr ich runter, komme unten an, und was sagen sie, ja, ich glaube, Gruppe zwei finde ich ganz gut. What? Und dann Gruppe eins, wer war in der Gruppe eins? Gruppe eins waren Leute ohne Beine. Ja, genau. Da kam wirklich dann die Katastrophenfelder an. Aber dann war ich in Gruppe zwei, meine Freunde alle in vier aufwärts immer so, geil, schwarze Piste, yeah, cool. Ich bin noch nie gefahren, aber wow, das ist cool. Das ist cool. Ich lasse meinen Helm mal bei euch, okay, das geht's. Und dann bin ich halt mit diesen Idioten, die ja überhaupt nicht Skifahren konnten und immer runtergekommen. Ich bin sehr gross, das ist mein Problem bei vielen Sportarten. Ich bin 1,96 groß und da habe ich dann bei solchen Sportarten, wo man sich bewegen muss, also ich stehe auf Skiern und stehe immer Kerzen gerade und meine Skier sind immer zu kurz und ich habe mal sehr lange Skier bekommen. Warum? Damals auf der Skifreizeit habe ich immer eine sehr lange Skier bekommen, weil da hat man immer gesagt, man nimmt die Körpergrösse durch mal zwei hoch x gleich y zum Quadrat, muss man dann mit der PQ-Formel auflösen. Und dann hast du die Länge der Skier herausbekommen. Und es waren bei mir sehr, sehr lange Skier, die es irgendwie nur einmal gab, in einem riesen Skiverleih. Und dann habe ich unfassbar lange Skier gehabt und bin dann zum ersten Mal gefahren in meinem Leben. Und da muss man ja auch relativ, man nimmt ja den Stock ja und dann nimmt man die Beine hoch und dann kann man halt diese Schlangenlinien fahren. Und das ging bei mir aber nicht, weil einfach so eine Tonne Schnee immer drauf lag, weil es halt unfassbare Tragflächen waren, meine Skier. Ist doch abgehoben, wer war es? Ja, ich bin genau, wie Skispringer, so lange Skier waren das. Und dann, ich konnte das einfach nicht mehr verbinden, fahren damit, ohne nicht gleich irgendwie im Schnee zu versinken. Und dann wurde mir nach dem dritten Tag oder so, wo ich immer an einer Stelle stehen geblieben bin, bis es irgendwann mal einem aufgefallen ist, dass es wahrscheinlich nicht die richtigen Skier sind, da wurde mir dann eine andere Skier gegeben. Und dann ging es auch einiger. Aber auch keine Chance auf Lenken, einfach Schuss gerade runter. Genau, du musstest gerade auch. Du musstest gerade auch. Du musstest gerade auch nicht lenken, ich muss jetzt sterben. Genau, tut mir leid., sorry, und immer, ich habe mir schon mal so einen Schuldigen, da bin ich schon an den anderen vorbeigesauht.
Entschuldigung, ich weiß nicht, was ist eigentlich passiert. Und dann, ich wurde aber auch nicht wirklich schnell, weil die Verdrängung halt bei diesen Riesen-Skiern auch enorm gross war. Und da habe ich die Lust sehr schnell verloren. Aber am Ende habe ich dann relativ kurze Skier bekommen, die dann nicht mehr mit der Formel der Körpergrosse übereinstimmen konnten, aber war besser.
Wir waren auch mal Skifahren in der Gruppe, also von der Schule, also einfach nur wir ein paar Freunde und haben auch ein paar Damen eingeladen, mit uns mitzufahren. Und eine war auch relativ unbedarft und es war so ein ganz süsses, braves Mädchen, das auch zu spät kam und ihre Mutter wollte unbedingt mitkommen, die war so ganz behütet und die ist aber Snowboard gefahren.
Und dann ist sie eben hochgefahren und wie, ja, wo bist du denn, wo bist du denn, wir warten oben auf dich ewig lang.
Und dann kommt sie endlich an, irgendwie mit ihrem pinken, pinke Mütze, pinke Anzug, alles da, okay, jetzt kann ich mitfahren, legt ihr Snowboard auf den Boden, will sich die Schuhe anziehen, Snowboard fährt ohne sie groß, fährt direkt den Berg runter.
Und dann wurde es relativ schnell, relativ ernst aus dieser zuckersüssen, ah schön, dass du da bist, hi hi hi hi Situation, wurde tatsächlich eine ernste Situation, weil ihr Snowboard ist schnurgerade und das kriegt ja eine wahnsinnige Geschwindigkeit, wenn es einfach so einen Berg runterfährt, ist auf eine Gruppe wartender Leute, die gerade beim Lift standen und warten. Und zwar standen die so ein bisschen, war das wie so eine Art Kerbe im Schnee, wo dieser Lift drin war, wo die Leute gewartet haben. Das heißt, dieses Snowboard kam wie auf einer Sprungschanze angerast und wäre den Leuten wirklich direkt gegen den Kopf geschlagen, die da gewartet haben, weil der Schnee auf der Höhe des Kopfes war, wo die gewartet haben. Das heißt, es hätte wirklich zu ernsthaften Verletzungen bis zur Enthauptung kommen können, wenn ich einer meiner Freunde todesmutig hinterhergefahren wäre, komplett alles rausgeholt hat und es tatsächlich noch abfangen konnte. Aber das war so eine Situation. Das wäre auch ein trauriger Tod, trauriger Tod, so eine Enthauptung durch ein Hello Kitty Snowboard. Ja, Mama, wann kommt der Lift endlich? Bats, Mama hat keinen Kopf mehr, einfach Mama. Und der Kopf fährt dann auf dem Snowboard runter, wenn es eine Comedy wäre, könnte man da viele tolle Dicks machen. Also es war so eine schöne Situation von, hey Leute, schön, dass ihr da seid, wollt ihr einen Kaugummi zu? Enthauptet überall Blut, schreiende Kinder, das war echt so ein... Wir hatten, wir hatten, ja, was, wolltest du noch einen Satz beenden? Nee, ich dachte, ich gehe mal so nonchalant, steige ich da ein. Grätsch einfach mal rein, wie ein Snowboard aus der Kontrolle. Wir hatten nämlich damals, bei der Skifreise hatten wir alle so Warnwesten an, orangene Warnwesten, damit uns die Lehrer erkennen konnten. Die ganze Klasse, es waren immer so 20 Leute, die man auf der Piste gut erkennen konnte, gut zum einen, weil sie unfassbar scheisse gefahren sind, zum anderen, weil sie ja diese orangene Warnwesten an hatten. Und dann ist der Lehrer eigentlich am dritten Tag mit uns direkt eine schwarze Piste runtergefahren und wir haben uns alle mega gefreut, es war eine super Stimmung, gelöste Stimmung, Leute haben applaudiert, haben ihre Helme hochgeschmissen, alle... Ganz kurz, muss man das erklären mit schwarzer Piste, verstehen? Also ich weiß nicht. Schwarze Piste sind Pisten, die sind, also die war sehr, sehr steil, die war unfassbar steil, und zwar wenn man da hinfällt, dann bleibt man nicht liegen, sondern man rutscht runter, so steil war die. Direkt ins Krankenhaus, man rutscht direkt ins Krankenhaus. Aufkt auf eine Liege ins Krankenhaus. Nee, das war wirklich, also man muss sich das vorstellen, wenn man sich hinlegt, man bleibt nicht drin liegen, sondern man rutscht wirklich runter, weil es unfassbar steil ist. Und dann sind wir erst alle so ganz langsam und da wurde plötzlich auch so eine Uhuh, wir fahren endlich mal schwarze Piste Stimmung, wurde dann schnell so alles ganz still und alle haben sich sehr konzentriert. So ein Testamentanruf beim Anwalt Stimmung. Genau, es war plötzlich so eine, puh, haben wir den richtigen Lehrer hierbei und da darf der bei uns, darf der uns überhaupt hier haben und es ist eine schwarze Piste und es war auch alles nebelig, war sehr weit oben, es war über 2000 Meter in Höhe und dann war plötzlich eine sehr ruhige Stimmung und so ein Eis, Eis, Blizzardmäßig hört man so im Hintergrund gehört. Und dann sind wir wirklich so ganz, ganz langsam den Berg längs und dann wieder eine ganz schnelle Kurve und dann wieder ganz langsam. Und dann eine sehr schnelle Kurve und dann wieder ganz langsam, bis irgendwann irgendwer ganz oben umgekippt ist und hat alle mitgerissen. alle mitgerissen, da sind alle diese unfassbar steilige Piste runtergerutscht. Und über mir ist ein sehr dicker Mitschüler hingefallen, der war dann sehr, sehr schnell plötzlich, also der wurde sehr, sehr schnell, bedrohlich schnell und hat halt irgendwie, war sein Skistock, war in seinen Skiern verkeilt, so dass er genau der Skistock mit dieser Spitze nach unten mir entgegenschoss. Und dann bin ich hochgesprungen. Das war ein Attentat. Das war ein Attentat. Das war unfassbar gruselig. Es war unfassbar schnell ging das alles und überall war Schnee und schreiende Kinder in Warnwesten. Und dann bin ich hochgesprungen. Ich bin hochgesprungen, er ist unter mir runter. Doch ohne Scheiß, das war Ultra. Das war das Sportlichste, was ich jemals gemacht habe. Hat es die süße Nina aus der Parallelklasse gesehen? Nee, die hat es nicht gesehen, es hat keiner gesehen. Alle waren mit sich selber beschäftigt und seinen eigenen Skiern. Überlebenstrieb, ja. Und dann ist der Einzige, der halt diesem Chaos aus Leuten, aus dieser Lawine aus Warnwesten entkommen konnte, war halt der Lehrer, der dann nach und nach alle Stöcker aufgesammelt hat und hat dann irgendwie so einen riesen Fächer aus Skistöckern in der Hand gehabt und hat uns alle eingesammelt. Das war sehr lustig. Und hat daraus so kleine Kreuze gemacht, die dann auf der Grab gelegt wurden. Schön. Aber es war auch bei mir so, als ich in meiner Zweiergruppe dann gefahren bin, und dann sind wir in einer grossen Schlange gefahren und ich sollte ganz hinten fahren, weil der Lehrer dann doch gemerkt hat, dass ich relativ der Beste bin aus der Gruppe. Aber ich hatte da so keinen Bock drauf und war so genervt, dass ich völlig abgelenkt war und dem Typen vor mir ganz nah aufgefahren bin. Und meine Aufgabe war dann, ja, wenn Leute hinfallen, dann fahrt sie hin und helft denen. Und ich hatte überhaupt überhaupt keinen Bock, ey, ich war völlig abgelenkt, total pisst und irgendwann ist der Typ vor mir hingefallen und ich bin einfach über ihn drüber gefahren, einfach direkt knallhart weitergefahren, gezogen, fick dich, ich gehöre dich hin. Das zeige ich euch auch. Auf Ski fahren habe ich auch immer diesen Ehrgeiz, der Wester zu sein. Und wenn mich jemand auf der Piste überholt, auch wenn ich nicht kann, habe ich das Ziel,
bevor man unten ist, den wieder zu überholen und ihn dann irgendwie so wegzuschubsen und
in den Graben zu schubsen nebenan.
Und auch wenn auch im Sturzflug, ohne Ski ist es mir egal.
Ohne Ski, ohne Talent, einfach nur, damit man vor dem noch ankommt.
Und wenn man überholt wird, das habe ich auf Autobahn, das habe ich auch auf Skibis, immer das Gefühl, muss man den wieder überholen.
Das ist eine Art Herausforderung. Überholen ist eine Art Herausforderung. Ja, stimmt schon. Siehst du, Sport ist doch gar nicht so schlecht das Thema. Hast du dir eine richtige Verletzung zugezogen? Ja, ich habe irgendwann plötzlich, als ich nie mehr Fussball gespielt habe, hat man ja doch manchmal noch irgendwie im Sportunterricht Fussball gespielt. Und dann habe ich immer jedes Mal, das war irgendwie jedes Jahr, hat man das mal halt im Lehrplan gehabt fußball oder ball sportart und jedes mal habe ich mir irgendwas an den adduktoren das ist in der leistengegend wenn man da ich habe geschossen und mein bein ist als gefühl als die hüfte wäre rausgesprungen das ist immer angefühlt also ich konnte nicht mehr gehen es war nicht es tat auch nicht weh großartig ich konnte einfach nicht mehr gehen es war einfach es ging nicht mehr und dann musste ich jedes jahr musste ich dann imussball gespielt haben, ins Krankenhaus gebracht werden, was direkt in der Schule war glücklicherweise.
Aber es war immer, wir haben Fussball gespielt, okay, gleich muss ich einfach ins Krankenhaus und es war immer wirklich so.
Ich habe mich tatsächlich noch nie verletzt, ich habe mir einmal in den Arm ausgekugelt, aber ansonsten gar nichts, ich war auch noch nie im Krankenhaus wirklich.
Das ist immer gut, gut im Podcast, wenn irgendwer eine Frage stellt, einfach immer ein Nein zu antworten.
Nein, kenne ich nicht. Habe ich nie gehabt.
Nie gehabt, nein.
Nee, habe ich nicht.
Möchte hier nicht drüber reden.
Habe ich keine Marokation.
Sie wollen dieses Prüfen-Thema noch.
Ach so, nee.
Wir kommen gleich zu unserem nächsten Thema.
Davor noch mal eine kurze Werbestrecke.
Bis dann, mach's gut. Bis gleich, ciao.
Lass uns mal die Werbung selber einsprechen.
Hey, haben Sie Durst? Dann trinken Sie doch einfach Coca-Cola. Nein. Coca-Cola. Die Cola für Sie. Coca-Cola. Und wir sind wieder drauf in drei, zwei und bitte. Ja, Stefan, wie war das Wochenende? Sehr gut war es, sehr gut war es. Ich bin mit allen Klausuren übrigens durch, was auch sehr lustig war. Die Klausur war übrigens gut, danke der Nachfrage. Es war so, ich habe ja in Köln geschrieben und es war mal wieder so eine Klischee-Explosion. Wir haben gerade geschrieben, alles war ruhig. Erstmal bin ich zur Uni gefahren und dann war an dem Tag war Weiber fastlacht und in der U-Bahn waren schon alle verkleidet. Und man kommt mit dieser Grundaufregung, zu einer Klausur schreiben zu müssen. In so einem Studentenoutfit fährt man halt sehr, sehr müde zur Uni und überall sitzen so verkleidete Menschen. Geister und Hexen und Sauber. Alle noch sehr, sehr, sehr müde und deren Gesicht hat nicht ausgedrückt, dass sie sich verkleidet sind. Also die sahen halt unumdurch lustig aus, alle haben sich Mühe gegeben mit dem Outfit, was sie sich eine Woche vorher überlegt haben, aber ihr Gesicht hat ausgesagt, ich sitze morgens in der U-Bahn und mir geht scheiße und es ist halt früh. Und das war sehr lustig, wenn so ein Pirat da sitzt, der halt eine unfassbare Fresse zieht, aber in Wirklichkeit wie ein Pirat aussieht. Das war sehr lustig. Und dann bin ich halt angekommen und dann war sehr
leise, alle haben geschrieben, konzentriert und dann draußen direkt vom Fenster zog halt so ein
Karnevalsumzug mit Trömmelsche und Fanfare vorbei. Das war halt typisch Kölner, denkt man aber auch.
Und währenddessen füllt man sein Arbeitslosenzertifikat auf, weil man genau weiß, es wird nichts mit der
Klausur. Es wird nichts, komm, nehm es zurück. Aber hast du ein paar Gags eingebaut in die Klausur? Nein, ich bin sehr humorbefreit, privat. Ich wollte tatsächlich mal in einer Logik-Klausur, und da denken jetzt die Leute, okay, Logik ist per Definition extrem humorbefreit, aber ich wollte einen Humor einbauen, und zwar unser Logik-Professor hat er davor irgendwie so ein Interview gegeben für die Uni, die hat irgendwie so Vorstellungsvideos für alle Professoren gemacht und da ist er dann mit der U-Bahn gefahren in München und hat dann so gesagt, ja, in der U-Bahn denke ich immer ganz gerne nach und die besten Ideen kommen mir zwischen den Stationen. Und das war so ein bisschen so ein Running Gag bei uns, weil das so lächerlich irgendwie ist, so ein komischer, klischeehafter Geniesatz, so die besten Ideen kommen zwischen den Stationen, was soll das bedeuten? Also völliger Schwachsinn. Und das war so ein bisschen ein geflügeltes Wort bei uns und dann gab es in der Logikklausur... Hast du geschrieben, die richtigen Antworten kommen wir zwischen den Aufgaben. Stimmt, guter Punkt, den hätte ich eigentlich auch machen können, aber da gab es dann irgendwie so ein Beispiel, so ein logisches Beispiel von wegen irgendwie so ein Satz, wo der Inhalt gleich ist, aber die verwendeten Zeichen sind anders irgendwie und man sollte irgendeinen einen Satz auf Deutsch und einen auf Englisch schreiben und bla, keine Ahnung, was da der tiefere Sinn dahinter war. Und dann als Beispielsatz wollte ich eben nehmen, die besten Ideen kommen zwischen den Stationen, einfach um richtig cool zu sein und dem Professor nochmal so einen kleinen Augenzwinkern zuzuwerfen zwischen den Papierzeiten. Aber ich wusste da nicht hundertprozentig, wie man den Satz ins Englische übersetzt, genau richtig. Und deswegen habe ich es dann auch gelassen, deswegen wurde der Gag dann auch. Es ist immer schade, wenn man alle Comedy-Opportunities nutzen würde, die es gibt auf der Welt, dann wäre es doch echt lustiger. Wäre man richtig lustig und arbeitslos. Das stimmt. Man sieht ja immer so auf die Nein-Gag oder anderen einschlägigen Blogseiten, Herr Tütze, es sieht man ja auch oft so lustige Klausuren, wo dann jemand geschrieben hat, ich habe einen Panda-Bär, der ist im Weg, deswegen kann ich die Antwort nicht hinschreiben und so. Kannst du dir vorstellen, dass es in deiner Schule jemals irgendjemand gemacht hat? Wir hatten immer sehr coole Leute, die coolsten Leute haben immer als erstes abgegeben, weil die nichts wussten. Und dann haben alle schon so gedacht, wow, der ist ganz schön cool. Also nichts weisen, die hat keiner gedacht, aber irgendwie war das doch so. Die coolsten Leute waren immer die, die als erstes abgegeben haben. Und die haben immer sitzen geblieben sind, weil sonst keiner aufs Klo hätte mehr gehen können. Ist doch so, bei euch auch gewesen, bestimmt, ne?, das stimmt schon. Die Coolsten haben es abgegeben, mussten dann aber noch da sitzen, uncoolerweise, weil halt sonst keiner aufs Klo mehr hätte gehen können. Ja, und haben dann irgendwie lustige Sachen gemacht. Genau, und da dachte ich immer, dass wenn dann, wenn jemand sowas macht, so lustige Sachen, der reinschreibt, dann die, die zuerst abgeben. Ja, gut, das stimmt schon. Ich kann mich an eine Rallye-Ex erinnern, wo irgendwie so ein Bild war von Jesus mit seinen Jüngern irgendwie. Und dann habe ich, crazy wie ich bin, habe ich Jesus auf die Brust geschrieben, so als hätte er so ein Motto-T-Shirt an, habe ich drauf geschrieben, Jesus Rocks. Ja, richtig lustig, so als hätte Jesus ein eigenes T-Shirt von sich selbst. Florentine Rocks. Hat Joyce Ilk eigentlich diese Keep it Joyce Ilk T-Shirt selber an eigentlich auch?
Vor allem diese T-Shirts, die sind so dämlich. Was heißt das denn?
Es gibt überhaupt keinen Sinn, ja. Keep it Joyce Ilk.
Nee, Joyce-Lick oder nicht? Was bitte?
Haben wir doch zusammen, man liest erst Keep it Joyce Ilk und dann denkt man so, was, das ist noch niemals ein Wort.
Stimmt, Joyce-Lick ist so wie scheusslich. Aber selbst das ist noch niemals ein Name. So heißt sie doch nicht. Keep it Luke Mockridgeig. What? Keep it Luke Mockridge. Keep it Florentin Willig. Willig. Wir sollten eigentlich T-Shirts drücken, Keep it Podcasting. So ein komplett, der von dem Rhythmus der Worte cool erscheint, aber inhaltlich überhaupt keinen Sinn ergeben. Moment, mir fällt noch ein, bei uns gab es einen Running Gag, auch in der Schule, weil bei uns hatte mal jemand eine Musikklausur, glaube ich, abgegeben, ein komplett leeres Blatt, und da waren so verschiedene Fragen, unter anderem zum Beispiel, was ist ein Concerto Grosso? Und dann hat er hingeschrieben, Concerto grosso ist ein grosses Konzert.
Und das war der einzige Satz und hat Lea abgegeben. Und seitdem wurden auf relativ random, auch in anderen Fächern, irgendwo der Satz untergebracht, Concerto grosso ist ein grosses Konzert, einfach nebenbei, damit der Lehrer noch was lernt nebenbei. Das fällt mir gerade ein, die einfachste Note, die ich jemals bekommen habe, die einfachste Eins, die ich jemals bekommen habe, war Musik. ZwölftonTon-Musik, für die, die es nicht kennen, sind einfach willkürlich irgendwelche Noten aneinandergereiht. Es muss scheisse klingen, aber es müssen alle 12 Halbtöne, die es halt gibt, auf Keyboards zum Beispiel, müssen darin vorkommen. Und dann habe ich mich einfach zu Hause ans Keyboard gesetzt und habe einfach jeden Ton irgendwie untergebracht. Und es gab eine Eins-Plus und ein Smiley, wo dran stand, sehr gut Stefan. Ja, das ist das Gute an dieser modernen, postideologischen Musik, dass man halt einfach nicht nach Guter bewerten kann, weil alles scheisse klingt. Es war das hässlichste Lied der Welt, es war das hässlichste, es war eine Eins-Plus, wo sogar noch sehr gut Stefan dran stand. Bei uns hat unser Musiklehrer irgendwann komplett aufgegeben und hat uns einfach Singstar spielen lassen und hat uns Noten, kein Blitz, hat uns Noten nach den Punkten bei Singstar gegeben. Das war irgendwie zehnte, elfte Klasse oder so, wo man eigentlich nicht mehr singt, knallhart, ja hier ist die Playstation, spielt Singstar, Lied könnt ihr euch selber aussuchen. Nein, ey da am Ende auch dann diese Symbole standen, du bist ein Topstar oder du bist ein Sternchen. Eine Eins, ja, ja. Sternchen Eins. Aber da hat sich der andere, weil es gab zwei Musiklehrer und einer war so der Slacker, dem alles scheißegal war, aber auch ein total süßer Kerl und der andere war so der Hardcore, der irgendwie selber komponiert hat und irgendwie in einem Chor in Japan gesungen hat oder so und der hat sich dann immer über den Typen aufgeregt, der immer Singster gespielt hat, das hat dann mit Musik nicht zu tun und hier und da, aber im Endeffekt hat wahrscheinlich auch der Rektor gesagt, Kollege, das ist Musik, das interessiert halt keine Sau. Bei uns war, wir hatten einen sehr gepflegten Musikraum, wo immer auch sehr viele Kabel waren für die Keywords und so und irgendwie sind andauernd Kabel verschwunden. Also es haben Schüler wirklich Kabel geklaut und so. Und einer hat mal versucht, wirklich einen Verstärker, einen Gitarrenverstärker mitgehen zu lassen, weil es dann sehr blöd aussah. Ja, dann will die uns seinen Pullover halten, so ein Riesengitall am Verstärker nach draußen.
Das kann man aber auch einfacher machen.
Ja, hätte man einfach machen können, genau. Aber es sind immer Kabel verschwunden und irgendwann haben dann die Lehrer eingeführt, dass man seinen Schlüssel abgeben musste oder sein Handy, um halt so ein Kabel zu bekommen, um dann Keyboard spielen zu können, also so ein Kopfhörer oder so, keine Ahnung, weil da so viele geklaut wurden. Und wenn man dann den Kopfhörer wieder abgegeben hat, hat man sein Handy wieder bekommen und konnte dann gehen. Aber Dinge aus der Schule zu klauen ist mir noch nie gekommen, ehrlich gesagt. In der Uni tatsächlich, da waren teilweise auch in komplett leeren Vorlesungssälen, zwischen Vorlesungen, die einfach stundenlang leer standen, waren also super krasse Mikrofone, die man einfach sollte mitnehmen können und Boxen und alles, wo ich mich gefragt habe, warum das niemand klaut. Macht man dann nicht, ne? Ja, Philosophiefakultät, die sind alle moralisch gefestigt, da hast du keine Chance. Da hast du keine Chance. Nächste Woche gibt's ... Ich habe tatsächlich ... Ja, ach so. Ja. Ne, ich würde die Anekdote auch gerne vertagen, können wir gerne nächstes Mal da reinhauen. Nächste Woche gibt's super Themen. Bevor wir schliesslich noch mal, wir machen noch ganz kurz Werbung, dann bist du mal gleich wieder da. Bis gleich. Ja, das war's schon langsam. Stefan Titzel, schön, dass du dabei warst. Vielen Dank für diesen schönen Abend. Bis zum nächsten Mal, würde ich sagen. Dann sind wir wieder bei. Wie immer kennt ihr, 17.30 Uhr fangen wir an, das Podcast-UFO live on air. Und ja, wenn ihr Themenvorschläge habt oder generelle Anmerkungen, schreibt sie uns, wir antworten euch nicht. Schreibt sie uns auf Twitter unter dem Hashtag P. Nächste Woche gibt es für nächste Woche noch ein kleiner Teaser. Nächste Woche fangen wir an mit unserer Rubrik. Wir wissen noch nicht genau, worum es geht, außer um ein Egal-Aal. Was ist das wohl sein? um einen Egal-Aal.
Es geht den kleinen Egal-Aal.
Schreibt eure Ideen bitte nicht.
Welche Abenteuer könnt ihr der Egal-Aal erleben?
Schreibt es uns auf Facebook, Twitter oder schreibt uns eine tolle iTunes-Rezension.
Ansonsten vielen Dank, Stefan Titzel, dass du auch heute wieder dabei warst.
Danke, Florian. Bis zum nächsten Mal. Wir müssen gleich noch synchronisieren.
Ansonsten macht's gut, wir heben ab, Ui bis dann!